you guys so today
i'm gonna unbox something for you this
is very exciting that i've been waiting
for
since they announced it let me just
finish this message really quickly here
okay
the magsafe duo charger it's here
[Music]
i feel like this is kind of the cop-out
for not having
air power but you know what i think this
is cool it's foldable i'm real into
foldable stuff i love wireless charging
so guess what i already know i'm gonna
like this so here is the charger
we have two sides so this is a charger
phone and this is to charge your apple
watch
this just flips up just like that you
see right through it
this also folds up to make it easy to
take for traveling
and i love that this has the little
apple logo on it the other thing that
you're going to notice is
there's no charging brick i do feel like
they
probably should have put one with this
because this is sort of like the whole
charging kit like you would need the
brick to charge
all of the things so they do give you
the usb-c cable so if you do get the
usbc charging brick then
you can use this
this has a little usbc port right here
wait a minute no hold on a second
it's lightning i was thinking this is
going to be usbc to usbc
but no it is lightning to usb-c
that could have been one of the ways
where we sort of made the iphone usb-c
by making this usb-c but i feel like
most people would probably already have
this cable but since i gave you a cable
i'm not really sure the logic behind it
but either way
this is exciting and i really love the
design of this
it has everything that you need to
charge your apple watch and to charge
your phone and also we have in here is
there's a little
did we get a little sticker in here
maybe okay no sticker but we do have
some paperwork i have a dog that's my
dog
that's my dog that's my dog are you guys
ready for the first charge
i am i like that this is able to flip up
because if you do have this type of
watch band you would probably have to go
like this to charge it
not quite ideal this way
are you charging you're charging you're
charging look
here we go watch is charging
and it just magnetically zipped itself
right into place
charging i mean this isn't really that
long of a video
but i was very excited about this
magsafe duo charger
that i really wanted to show it to you
guys and i just got it so i really
wanted to
give you guys the first look at the duo
charger this is such a great idea
and that's it here it is magsafe duo
super cool let me show you the
magneticness
of this thing look at that look at this
it's pretty sturdy
[Music]
[Applause]
i wonder if i can charge it here on the
other side
probably not but let's try it
one side charge only we had to test it
well thank you guys so much for watching
this really quick video probably the
quickest video i've ever posted
since i don't know like 2007 but i have
more iphone videos planned for you guys
so stay tuned if you guys aren't
subscribed to my channel be sure to do
so and hit the bell so you're notified
when i post a new video but if you
haven't seen my iphone 12 pro
max and 12 mini unboxing video be sure
to go check that out as well and i'll
see you guys in the next video
bye